nft stands for non-fungible tokens it's
the biggest technology that's ever
happened in the history of life outside
of things like [ __ ] fire and like the
printing press is the one that i keep
going back to television phone fine but
this is like printing press 10.0
contemporary artists should really be
looking at this technology i think it's
a a huge win for the artist financially
and brand reputationally and for its
early buyers there was no option for
them not to use the high market art
world infrastructure a gallery an
auction house i believe this gives them
options what people are talking about
are you've covered the people auction
the 69 million dollar sale and all that
but people are misunderstanding the
smart contract and what it can do these
are smart contract visualization right
homes and leases i can't imagine not
every ticket being an nft in a decade
once i realized it was this big big i
only know one move all in every person
that's watching this right now that is
lucky enough to be alive in 15 years
will own multiple things digitally
people are gonna fixate that it's just
on collectibles and art but it's a
platform everyone's gonna say that you
you're just saving a jpeg just like
people fixated that social media was
just for kids social currency it's why
mercedes and nike matter it's also how
you express yourself everybody i'm
looking at right now and behind the
camera is literally wearing the clothes
they're wearing as a subconscious way to
communicate to the world everything we
do is to communicate with each other as
we inherently live more digital forget
about the metaverse ready player one we
live in the metaverse now people are in
their screens constantly i already know
sitting here in 2021 that the public
wallet with all your nfts in it will
become the next social media that when
jason hit my radar are we gonna hire
this guy just like we looked at his
wikipedia if he had one linkedin if he
had one instagram if he had one but in
2027 i'm gonna look at his wallet and i
believe what's in his wallet is a much
better indication to who he is than what
pictures he decided to pr to the world
this next six to twelve months greed
will take over everybody will put out
nfts people will buy trade sell steal
rip off try to trick you and do the
wallet there'll be so much happening it
will collapse there is an absolute
guaranteed nft winter coming 98 of the
projects will go to zero but it doesn't
mean the nft space is going to zero it
means that the craze of the gold rush
just like internet stock in 99 will get
people to make bad short-term decisions
that's gonna create a lot of headlines
in 2023 2024 that nfts were fed nfts
were [ __ ] but then just like 2004 and
five with internet when everybody made
fun of people who lost money on internet
stocks the internet rose like a phoenix
and ate up our world i am completely
convinced that's gonna happen in nft
world a lot of you right now saying
you're never going to own one
and all of you will
so do with that
what you want
[Music]